The joe rogan experience, years
of years of competition, you know,
all day the problem at the colitis
and all that. That's because of that,
that that bs that I got it like
putting too much on me. Normally fight,
fight again. It will be, it will go back
that same pattern. I will, I will not be,
I will be very stressed and it's normal
to be stressed, but I will accept it.
I accept it better now than I
used to do when I was younger.
Now after you won the title,
there was thoughts of whether or not
you would defend it if you were going to
fight Robert Whitaker, like
what you were going to do, what,
what caused your decision? What made
you decide to relinquish the belt?
So the reason why I
relinquish your belt is ag.
I went to do some physical
tests to see what, what,
what does that problem with my
El Condition? Because during the,
the Cap I knew I had problem. I didn't
know what it was. I knew it was, you know,
that tests, the blood tests and everything
for the cancer, it came negative.
So after I went to do like, like I say,
colonoscopy, it came back that I uh,
no sorry,
inside my stomach
that as a doctor I say how long it takes
to get rid of this is I is whole your
life. But the symptom, the symptom can
go up, down, depending every people,
whatever they do differently.
Then I started researching was the
best doctor I'll can I do this.
And that's when I started reading
about like the fasting and stuff and I,
and I then I, then I tried it, but
I saw that a lot of it
in that sport of MMA,
a lot of the guys are a starving day.
They know they're not hungry,
they are not rich.
You know,
I'm lucky now have enough
money for the rest of my life.
I don't need to fight anymore.
You know,
if I don't do nothing crazy like buying
a private airplane and I'm not that kind
of person or falling into drugs and
stuff and I, I think I'm good, you know,
for me, my family and
everything, I think I'm good.
However APP when I'm looking at
the landscape, I say a lot of guy,
like for example,
condo met Gregory,
he hold on to the title two to 40
attention the sponsors at this and that,
and I love people do that. That kind
of, they kind of stole the division.
And I'd said to my side, I
said, you know what I stand for,
for the fighters always did,
you know, and publicly as her,
why am I gonna keep that title until to
see if I feel better or not and defend
it because I don't even know if my leg,
my weight that it was dropping down.
It's like I,
I'm not even,
no one 85 or a Memoriam one
70 or one 50 Fiverr's I'm not,
I don't have the size of a one 85 hours.
So I'm like,
I, I relinquished it right away. You know,
I don't want to install the division and
make people wait because of me and that
they're the, well, don't go around
me. You know what I mean? So far,
the respect I did,
I did it,
but I didn't know before the fight I
was going to do it is it happened like
[inaudible] like this people, I was like,
oh yeah. You know, not knowing. No, I did.
I didn't know he was going,
I didn't know it was going to have
it called ids and all that stuff. He,
it came up, I never tried it before. I
didn't know what would be the outcome,
how I would feel. I never
did it. You know, it was a
test. And this same, no bad.
I didn't know. You know, I have a
lot of, uh, I'm not a perfect man.
Joe Have a lot of, uh, negative stuff
about me. My one thing that I'm not, is,
I'm not a coward. This I where if
I say I'm going to do something,
I'm going to do, I'm not a coward,
you know, and every of my fight,
every of my fight I was, I'm
scared. I'm scared. I'm terrified.
But whatever. I feel, I
step. And I, and I, I, uh,
I respect Mike on trek and
I do it, you know, and, um,
I didn't, I didn't know the
colitis and all that. It was,
it would be illogical right now if we,
if I want to go back when I'm ready to
go back one, eight five, I'm not one 85,
you know? Right, right.
It would be a stupid move.
And so if you're gonna fight again
and it'd be one 70 or one 55 yes.
What were, were you leaning?
Are you leaning towards 55 or 70
I don't know. I, I'm, I'm Leah,
I'm gonna. I want to lean. We're,
if I, I want, you know what
af climb the Everest many
times. You know, I've climate,
once I lose to Matt Hughes
and I climate too, I loosed,
I then I, then I got it, then I
lose to Matt Serra. I climate again.
I've done it like three times.
And you're like, I'm 37 years old.
I just turned 37 few,
few days ago.
I don't want to have much less.
Right. And the far what have left.
I want to make the, the, the big fight
that fight, that the fan want to see,
they want to enjoy.
Um,
I also want personal need for me to
achieve something that is unique,
that is rare, that maybe that never
been attempted before. You know,
that would be something that excites me.
And I'm not only driven by
money, you know, like, like,
like a, it's good to have
money. We like money. It's,
it drives us all, including myself, but
it's not the unique thing that drives me.
It need to be more than
money and they need,
need to be some kind of achievement that
comes with it. That would exciting me.
Okay.